[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici pour les exactement ex se sont
évadés en ce dimanche matin ensoleillé
ils sont près d'un millier réunis au
Parc du Colosse à Saint-André prêt à sé
lancé pour cette première édition de la
tropica dingue ou on est prêt team
j'aime la Bou j'aime la Bou jusquau bout
par vague successive les équipes
prennent le départ pour une épreuve
sportive et ludique d'une dizaine de
kilomètres tout à fait sur à peu près 10
à 12 km avec 10 obstacles que les gens
doivent s'amuser sur les obstacles parce
que c'est pas une épreuve sportive c'est
plus une épreuve de cohésion où les gens
vont s'amuser et cetera c'est tous se
retrouver ensemble bien rigoler ou quoi
que ce soit effectivement avec le soleil
la chaleur et ou quoi que ce soit sur la
fin du parcours se jeter dans les temps
c'est le c'est le top c'est le
top derer là allez
Farinette c'est parti pour
2h et c'est parti pour 2h d'une course
dingue par se mett d'obstacles que les
concurrents doivent franchir en
s'entraînant sach quand même des équipes
de une personne quand même
malheureusement voilà c'est beaucoup
l'entra entre équipe et puis ça se fait
je pense que c'est l'une des épreuves
les plus difficiles c'était
difficile plus pour descendre la
réception était moyenne mais bon moiussi
je su fait mal à la main
mais qu même oui on l'a voulu c'est
quand même marrant oui on continue on
lâche pas jusqu'au bout personne
n'abandonnera ven des avirons Ding
orange sont les premiers à franchir la
ligne d'arrivée fatigués mais heureux ah
bien bien c'était vraiment super bien
super organisation c'était chouette très
bien impeccable bien humide peu de
soleil
parfait bien mouillé c'est super bien à
refaire avec près d'un millier de
participants pour cette première édition
la tropica Ding est déjà une réussite un
succès à mettre également à l'actif des
partenairire de cette manifestation et
notamment des agriculteurs de
l'association produit pays réunion ils
sont venus nous voir pour être
partenaire dans le casadre Tropic gading
on a tout de suite compris que ce sont
des sportifs et qu'effectivement il
fallait queon associer la marque produit
pays runion qui est une fabrication
proprement locale à 100% pays et donc
nous devons nous être présent à cette
asion à cette occasion pour nous montrer
pour être visible sur tout le site quoi
l'idée c'est d'avoir quand même des
produits sains peut-être pour les
sportif proposer un petit peu tout ce
qui se fait à la Réunion et qui est
produit à la Réunion et puis voilà voir
qu'on peut avoirim tion Scine aussi ici
à la Réunion voilà c'est voilà
partenaire pour cette année tropiing
peut-être l'année prochaine aussi donc
on l'espère en tout
[Musique]
cas organisé pour la première fois au
Parc du Colosse à Saint-André la
tropicading a réuni en ce dernier
dimanche de novembre près de
participants autour d'une épreuve
sportive et ludique une course dingue de
10 km avec des obstacles à franchir et à
l'arrivé le bonheur de l'avoir fait on
commence ensemble on finit
ensemble magnifique
magnifique on VI des égous on est t nin
Tor ninja en fait et du coup on est des
guerriers voilà avec des
écaillesire peut-être ah oui absolument
vivement la deuxè édition mais cette
fois-ci on retourne tout d'accord
c'est trop cool vivons l'année prochaine
un bisous à ma mère un bisous à edit
c'est ma mère allez bisous après
l'effort le réconfort pour les sportifs
autour d'un bon repas préparé avec des
produits pays partenaire de cette
manifestation c'est une marque 100 %
réunionnaise donc tout est fait du début
jusqu'à la fin à la Réunion donc il y a
une traçabilité complète donc vous avez
de la viande des œufs des légumes quand
on voit les étiquettes voilà c'est ça
donc avec cette étiquette là donc c'est
des produits 100 % r fait déjà bonne
merci beaucoup bonne journée c'est
manger sain manger frais et c'est pour
ça que produit pays réunion qui véhicule
ce genre de message et on a voulu
s'associer avec un événement sportif
bonjour un petit peu de pou un petit peu
de un petit peu des de un pe les deux
c'est
parti alors on propose un chops poulet
et un caris por avec des grillades donc
du poulet du porc aussi et puis riz
grain rougail une petite salade de
fruits en en
dessert prod du pays bien sûr toujours
un menu très appétissant qui visiblement
est apprécié par tout le monde un peu de
tout je crois je plus un car por je
crois un petit CHS poulet un des petits
achards un petit r tomate ouement on va
bien remplir le ventre après la dépense
d'énergie alors après les for le
réconfort là qu'est-ce qu'ONI bah oui
tout à fait il y a du poisson il y a du
poulet il y a du porc pour tous les
goûts en fait donc voilà pour une
première édition c'est génial jamais
vécu on a plein de Bou de partout vous
regardez on a eu des câins gratuits
c'était super super super ah oui l'année
prochaine on revient c'est super génial
manger merci bien au
[Musique]
revoir
fore